My name is Luka Perković, and I'm the mid-laner for G2 Esports.
I actually never had goals of
actually going pro.
I had goals of living the normal life or just
going to school you know playing games
for fun. I started watching some LCS and
it's just like fun to watch these games
and this pro players. I climbed in
solo queue and at one point when I
joined the G2 challenger team, and it was, again I didn't want to go pro.
I just wanted to get some money you know. It was like my school summer break
and I was like oh, free money if I'm good.
Trick comes in for some relief pitching the pitches on. Hybrid getting chomped.
And now Perkz gets a killing spree to pick up Amazing. Looks for power, and that's a double kill for the fish.
My parents knew that I was really the game and I found a way to basically do exams in the
off-season, so we found a compromise.
So we qualified with the lineup: Hybrid, Jesse, Smittyj and Kikis as jungle that was like
a pretty special lineup. In the off-season we made some roster changes some people didn't
really like to play with each other and
it was a miracle that we won in relegation.
We didn't even know the lineup for a long
time. We didn't know if Kikis was going to stay
jungle or he wanted to role swap. My only aim was like top 4 or something.
Yeah I guess we exceeded all the
expectations.
I didn't really get affected by people's opinions like on Reddit or whatever about MSI
or my performance or teams performance at MSI because I knew how I felt
and how I played. After MSI I guess
I wanted to prove people again
Everyone was trash talking us
like oh, G2 is going to be shit
G2 vacation blah blah blah. And now we are first again.
It'll be very hard for G2 to play here. Power of Evil. Perkz actually turning on Power of Evil in the mid lane
he's going to flash away but the ignite will take him down but the first blood over to Perkz.
The complete meta change and members
change and roster change made us play
a bit different at beginning and
meta was like, mid centric so I had a hard time
Not really a hard time, but it took me some time to realize how the meta is different
and how I should play a lot more safe and smarter.
I would like to play SKT and RNG because I think at MSI we got stomped
by SKT both games but versus RNG
we were both games ahead and we could have easily won versus them.
I actually just want to win versus RNG. I want a revenge versus RNG.
I just want to play the best Korean and Chinese teams and i would like to face TSM actually.
TSM is like, so good in NA and they're very good players
and very good mid laners, so I'm looking forward to playing those teams.
In the end he's still going to drop and Perkz the triple kill.
What! The quadra kill coming in, this man 1v5 the Vladimir.
Right now, we are a completely different team. We play only straight macro game and we don't go
for clueless team fighting like before so
that's I guess what I learned from my first split
Clueless aggression is not good, that's why I got punished for it even in finals.
I've known them for a very long
time, I have known their personalities
and I knew how good of players they were. Like, we trust each other and can
always say like criticism or I don't
think the champ is good or maybe strong
and blah blah
now everything is going by the plan we
are improving so much, playing a complete
objective game and there are barely any stupid mistakes.
G2 is going to win Worlds, so we're going to make up for it.